Odell Beckham's sideline energy on
Thursday right head-butting the the fan
right it's weird I don't want people
think it's a fan of the game it's a fan
that produces air yes and he's yelling
and all that stuff and then he walked
off at halftime to get an IV and people
were like oh he's walking off on the
team and after the game he was super
pissed freakiest athletes have to get
IVs at halftime this is like just like
LeBron had to get an IV in San Antonio
when it was a hundred and ten in that
building the freakiest athletes all get
IVs that have to end when usually when
you see tape because they don't have
enough body fat on their body cuz
they're so freaky that they cramp up
after about the forty a sprint in a row
like Odell Beckham jr. severs like he
does not having fat lead you to get
crimps because your body basically has
no body fat to burn at this point so
then the muscles start to get dehydrated
and cramp there's nothing there for him
it's it's truly the freakiest guys I
ever played but they were always the
ones that had to go in early and get an
IV when you see a guy with tape right
below their elbow just white tape or
black tape but tells that shows you they
got an IV at halftime mmm what is did
you did any of that come back to you
anyone mention anything about Odell's
quote-unquote antics no I mean I I heard
you know what everybody was saying you
know again it are there's too much
attention on Odell stop putting the
camera he's yelling on the sidelines
sidelines there was I bet you like 30
other people who yelled on the sidelines
during that game uh I did a PI better or
whatever but the camera doesn't leave
him because of the reputation he's built
so he's put himself in that but I as a
guy don't look at it and go oh man this
guy's he's he's off the handle he's lost
his mind I don't look at it the way I
know what he is I've been with those
type of players like I've had this
conversation you know with Brandon
Marshall Brandon Marshall has been on
here to tell you I was always the
Brandon Marshall his right his right
pulmonary vein was about to pop out of
his neck after the second series and he
hadn't gotten the ball and I always had
to go over to him back chill out chill
out big guy it's coming don't worry it's
only been six plays so far hold on but
that's what makes those guys
and they're very emotional what's how I
came away with it because I went online
and I I'm just constantly amazed at
people's reactions to Odell if you have
a problem with Odell sidelines energy
you are the problem if you don't like
his sideline energy you're never allowed
to root for LeBron you're never allowed
to root for Kobe you're never allowed to
root for Jordan you are afraid of
passion what about Tom Brady you're not
allowed to root for ya you are devoid of
emotion right you carry around hand
sanitizer and love to wait in lines I do
like hand sanitizer nice well you're
half the way that you're the problem
with the Giants you're the reason they
can't move on from Eli because you are
intimidated by a player caring so much
that he's going to yell yeah if he would
have went and scored a touchdown right
after that they'd be giving the fan a
parade yeah right
but instead because it's failing it's
another thing that we can point on Brian
Dawkins would turn into a literal
character and would claw and run around
and would yell at the highest of his
volume and he's in the Hall of Fame
because he brought a passion to the game
offensive guys are not allowed to yell
defensive guys can yell and can scream
but Odell it's seen as diva DES it's
seen as diva why can't they care why
can't these guys yell and try to get a
rise out of somebody because it's a lot
better than this I hear you I mean Eli's
catching flies like can I get a lie on
the bench with a coach looking over the
film can you get Eli on the bench
yelling at guys in the offense what I'm
Brady does know instead it's a lie
sitting there just kind of looking off
in the distance I know so here's the
deal man Odell is trying to lead right
now
Odell is trying to get an emotion out of
people and and I'm not gonna sit here
and let people bash him for being the
only real leader on this team right now
yeah I heard that because I'm not seeing
it from Eli no I'm seeing zero
leadership know the leadership it truly
does look like it's Odell and say Kwan
Barclay really for the most part I'm
that's the funny thing about it and you
know again I'll go back to the fact that
you don't hear any of the players
complaining about Odell Beckham jr. ever
never and trust me if it was that bad
crusty report we would have already
heard that players in the locker room
are quietly complaining they don't
because they know he's not over there
yelling at anybody specific it's about
winning it's about playing better he
wants himself to play better but that's
it's kind of the bet he's built for
himself two-degree Hey look I just say
what one more thing before you finish it
yes huzzah Odell told everybody the
facts and people freaked out and said
that he was selfish and it wasn't the
right way to do it right we're realizing
is people have an issue with the facts
and people don't like to be wrong one of
the greatest investment firms it's the
top investment firm in the world it's
called Bridgewater Investments it's turn
over a year to year brings in more money
than Google Amazon and like Netflix
combined and the number one rule they
have at their company is you need to
argue with people in a productive way
right then if you were to come to the
idea meeting and you brought a pitch
yeah if I don't break down the what's
wrong with your pitch I'm the one that
could get fired because it's it's built
into the DNA of the company that if you
disagree with something you bring it up
right if they find out that you disagree
with someone didn't say anything you
could be fired that the only way they're
gonna get better is if they question
everything right all I hear about from
NFL locker rooms is accountability but
really what I'm learning about it is
when they say accountability when you
mess up take the blame when you're a
player that's what it sounds like it is
oh you blew that tackle be accountable
stand up in front of the rest of your
team and say you missed the tackle right
but when a coach makes a mistake
god forbid when a quarterback makes a
mistake and he's a future hall-of-famer
god forbid right but the only people
that are supposed to be accountable
are the guys that are not the
quarterback in the coach pretty much now
I will say that I listen to Sean McVeigh
who beats Denver in Denver and he comes
out there and says quote I put us up in
some horrible spots throughout the game
by really getting impatient the cold
didn't mess with the team but it may
have affected my brain we have a coach
that's willing to say that my brain is
messed up and the Giants can admit that
Eli sucks I know now get over yourselves
yeah that was your assignment but that's
why that's why that team will run
through a wall for Sean McVeigh run
through a wall right cuz they're gonna
they're gonna also go yeah he's right he
should have we were we did throw it a
few times man it's great to hear him say
that it great to hear that he's realized
that itself scattered oops I'm just
seeing what's happening with this and
I'm seeing what's happening with Hodel
and I do not believe there is any
position in sports that is more
separated from the fans than the quote
diva wide receiver wide receivers
especially those with personality are
the furthest from the fans fans love
unshaved underpaid offensive guards they
want to have beers with them they want
to hang out because they're not that far
but an african-american loud spoken
having tattoos wide receiver that's
being paid 90 X their salary they hate
him yeah they are scared of them they
think that they're divas they should be
happy with their money they should shut
up the reason they are that great is
they are who they are and I think that
there is nothing that magnifies the
issues in our country then Odell Beckham
jr. and people think that I hype on it
it's because the fans have an issue oh
Dells not doing anything wrong he's the
only guy that's going hey I will take
the full brunt of being the one that
calls out Eli I will do it I will
sacrifice my mentions I will sacrifice
all of my well-being my sanity because
this is what's right and they're getting
mad at them and really what it's showing
me his fans got an issue with outspoken
black athletes it's the truth shut up
and drivel shut up and dribble that's
what I'm learning that's why I get so
angry I learned from watching how people
treat O'Dell yeah I don't get treated
like this
a white loudmouth media guy that is
allowed to go back home and not deal
with anything no one writes oh shut up
and just you know be what it's
disrespectful I know there's a huge
element in this it's the most blatant
dichotomy I've ever seen I I agree I I
really do and I think there's you know
yeah listen there's it's hard for me to
argue that I don't argue any of that I
mean I think you're totally right I mean
it we could go back to the Brady thing
of Brady yells at times you're
especially used to back in is yeah
people say oh but Brady's won
championships yeah I know what do you
think he like do you think Odell doesn't
want to I don't think is not interested
in things interested in his stats I know
no he's interested what in the games I
know you know Brady could scramble for a
first down a point first down and do it
real animated and if Cam Newton does the
same thing everybody goes shut up and
get back in the huddle that's it's I
noticed it all the time man I mean I I
really do no matter what room I'm in and
here's and here's the last fact yeah if
you think that I'm trying to like race
bait or you think that I'm trying to do
this to like create like whatever I do
not care what you think the only people
I give a [ __ ] about are the guy across
from me Josh and the people that listen
to our show yeah and they're the people
that are saying everybody else like is
trying to make media everybody else is
trying to make videos now we just talk
the truth and they happen to go out yeah
I'm not trying to do anything no I know
I know and I'm just trying to be an
advocate for people like this that are
[ __ ] human I get you yeah right
I think you're right and I love that Tom
Brady does it too but he doesn't doubts
the way I would be if I was quarterback
I would be like Tom Brady I mean that's
the way I was I'd be animated and want
to piss the defense off a little and you
know be that animated but yes you're
right it's a different rule for certain
players and it's not fair and look at
yourself like think about oh he should
just sit there and take it okay then it
your job yeah when something happens to
you and you really disagree with it and
you sit there and take it you're gonna
go home you like I'm such a wimp I'm
such a loser I'm a lemming I go a bad
I'm not saying you are I'm saying like
if you don't people that go through life
and allow
things to happen them and don't take
heat and don't take action then you
can't criticize others because if you're
gonna take to your Twitter fingers and
you're gonna put it out there like it's
really upsetting to you do it in your
own life or just please put your picture
to it